neck pillow good morning John it's
Friday do is record a very quiet video
that's a simple request we are now in
Arizona oh wait we're going across the
river we are now in California Arizona
we are in California we are at the Jesus
Christ is Lord travel said John you are
wearing a neck pillow I'm wearing my
neck pillow John I'm here today with
number one New York Times bestselling
author of The Fault in Our Stars John
Green I think I'm so tired
how does it feel to be number one I mean
it's ridiculous I love their invite to
area so much I mean I would like to take
credit for it but it is it has nothing
to do with me it is kind of cool that
you could have written like a really
horrible book a lot of reordered it and
then they would have gotten to be like
oh my god I know but instead you wrote
an amazing book blog Grossman in Time
magazine you were damn near genius near
well how does that feel I don't know you
tell me as John says in the shows my
greatest accomplishment is being that's
my favorite joke in the show I love it
yeah that and the fact that almost every
night you get shocked instead of me
you're very empathic as you said last
night I was nervous I said empathic when
I meant empathetic I'm I also am
empathic they're little weird um
anything no moist you're right I see I'm
totally right please he's always
thinking of the moist what do you do
when you're backstage before sure to get
to get ready
um I mostly just sit and watch you play
the same chameleon
circuit song over and over and over
again
I'm very nervous andthat's it's one of
the only things that make me not well
you know what what would make me less
nervous is if you were practicing the
songs you are going to play oh oh the
glory of it all our interview is nearing
its end because John has a hamburger
thanks for interviewing many final words
for the people of my audience I hope you
guys like the ball in their stars and
thanks for being awesome
[Music]
it's
case you're wondering how we spend the
moments before we go on stage it's
disgusting